the jurogan experience you want your
name to be called one time
and that's what the announcement says
refereeing this fight is such and such
you don't want any complaints other than
that because we know it's a lifetime
opportunity for these fighters
we don't want to do anything negatively
to affect them so that's a good thing
well it's such a difficult job because
in impul
you have an impulse like you don't know
when to stop like is it now
is he okay is he gonna be okay like
sometimes fights get stopped early and
it is the worst feeling when a guy is
kind of rocked
but then someone stops the fight and
then the guy complains and that
the crowd's like boo and you're like
[ __ ]
it's you know what's weird because our
philosophy and
you know i primarily work with two of
the commissioners nevada state athletic
commission in california two of the top
commissions in the world
you don't want to fight to go too long
to risk long-term injury for the fighter
so there's that philosophy of maybe
stopping a fight one punch too early
versus one punch too late your goal is
to stop it right on time
but it takes a lot of hard work to get
to that point depending upon the history
of the fighter
you know their ability to come back and
you know you got to make that subjective
determination right away when is the
time to stop that fight but man it's the
worst feeling in the world if you think
you get to that point you let it go too
long
or if you mistakenly stop it too early
oh god it's a hard feeling and trust me
such a difficult job it's so much harder
than anything other than fighting
like everybody else is like judging is
kind of hard but they kind of they can
hide
like you're on tv that's right you know
you're right there if it happens and if
it's you
that makes a bad call like all the the
hate comes your way
and you know you got to kind of stay
away from you know some of the social
media criticism because you got someone
there
that may not understand the detailed you
know specifics of how we officiate and
what we do
and you're going to have critics not
tell everybody going into a fight fans
are going to hate you or love you
half of the fans are counting for a
fighter in the red corner half accounts
for fighters in the blue corner
and depend upon the call you make it may
be the referee's fault it may be the
judge's fault
but your goal is to go in there and
being as objective as possible and
fighter safety is always number one
yeah and some guys just want to see
people get beaten
almost to death they they don't want to
to be stopped even if the guy
is covering up and in a turtle they
think
they should they shouldn't stop the
fight if you stop a fight while somebody
is standing up
you're just going to get crucified for
that so well there's a call like with
max
holloway and calvin cater there was a
lot of people thought you could have
stopped that fight
standing up but herb was like not quite
and i think it was the right call he
gave them
but it was touch and go you could tell
he was looking at calvin
very carefully and there's that you know
you obviously go to
there's no one better than john mccarthy
and herb dean right doing this
for so long that's the goal so their eye
of what they're looking at
and also it comes down to intelligent
defense yeah
that's not just holding your hands up
that needs to translate into doing
something offensive
and if you could tell that a guy is
listening to your verbal commands and
he's doing something to fight back
as long as he's showing some good
cognitive skills and showing something
offensive where he's not looking at
long-term injury
there's a possibility of him letting
that fight go but man if it's starting
to stem on a 10-7 round where the
fighters just get destroyed and they're
going to get hurt now it's our
responsibility to step in with fighter
safety
yeah it's it's a like i said it's a very
difficult job but you do it well you do
it excellent
one of the best catch new episodes of
the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience